One of the things we do know is that,
you know,
as you stretch out the inequality you make men particularly on the lower end of
the distribution,
more and more likely to be aggressive.
It's sort of like imagine every man has a threshold for violence.
Um,
and status is important,
demand knocked that it's not important to women,
but it's different.
It's a different kind of status.
It status is important to men because it's one of the things that makes them
marketable as partners to women.
So it actually turns out to be quite important to Mandan.
Men tend to compete with one another for status,
hierarchy position and in a really unequal society.
If you're like a low rung guy then and you don't have any opportunity to rise
because the society isn't structured so that there's mobility,
then the more aggressive guys tend to turn into criminality and you know,
and so you could say there's a threshold for criminality and the more inequality
pressure you put on a particular area,
geographic or political area,
the more inequality pressure you put on it,
the more men slip past that threshold and into criminality.
And you know,
there's been pretty good studies done of drug gang in Chicago.
That was the best one is sociologist actually went and hung out with a drug gang
for,
he got into it.
I guess the drug gang leader was,
no,
I wouldn't say necessarily narcissistic,
but that might be a reasonable way of thinking about it.
And he was kind of happy with the idea of maybe being a subject of a book and,
and so this guy was able to associate with them,
got to know them quite well.
And then the housing project in which the gang was housed was slated for
demolition and the gang broke up and he got the books because they kept books.
And what he found was the average street drug dealer,
first of all was employed in another job as well and was making far less than
minimum wage now.
But the guy is,
you know,
further up the chain of course followed the Prieto distribution.
And so there was a tiny minority of them who were raking in a tremendous amount
of loot.
And the guys at the bottom,
we're just waiting around for the possibility that they could rise up the
hierarchy and you know,
it's pretty violent game.
So the chances that someone is going to be
taken out is pretty high and then a little slot opens up for some opportunistic
second rater and perhaps he can move up the hierarchy.